iran du trop lent souvent avoir regagné
qui va aller jusqu'à tes orteils petite
poche du midi pour julliard boury sa
fille julie et mères monoparentales et
habite sainte thérèse au nord de
montréal représentante pour un courtier
en alimentation elle parcourt plus de
500 km par semaine en voiture la hausse
du prix de l'essence lui coûte 100 $ de
plus par mois
ça me dit que je peux faire 432
de route environ presque 60 de
ce soir quand maman à la rive on se
dépêche pour aller au corps et l'a
laissé anaïs à l'école puis nous avons
discuté de son stress face à l'inflation
julie doit maintenant tout calculé pour
ne pas s'endetter et la jeunesse
beaucoup beaucoup de gymnastique
par son métier et le constate à quel
point le prix des aliments a explosé lui
aussi notamment les viandes à ma passion
était la grande par exemple on passe de
250 grammes 200 grammes avec une
augmentation de 3 on l'a même preuve
encore là pour elle c'est un autre 100
dollars de plus à payer chaque mois ça
c'est l'épicerie base y'a pas de
gâteries à travers et ce qu'il reste de
la place pour les loisirs de moins en
moins
des choix également à faire
nathalie lavallée a aidé les citoyens
comme julie aux prises avec un casse
tête financier chaque semaine cet hiver
une vingtaine de nouveaux ménages des
basses-laurentides lui demande conseil
on note que de plus en plus des familles
des travailleurs nous appelle nous
sommes plus grande détresse j'ai
toujours eu nos populations vulnérables
qu'on connaît mais ça touche monsieur
madame tout le monde maintenant les gens
ont vraiment de plus une difficulté à
combler leurs besoins de base
elle estime qu'une famille doit
maintenant gagner 80 mille dollars bruts
par année pour éviter les tracas de
l'endettement le revenu moyen des
ménages québécois est d'environ 85 mille
dollars avec deux enfants en bas âge
actuellement pense que ménages en mode
80 m par année et son parle logements
très raisonnable ça serait la limite non
parce que avec l'explosion des coûts
avec l'explosion des coûts si niveau des
hypothèques
ça se corse
c'est quoi ça
divisées
[Musique]
et ça se corse même pour ceux comme la
famille fauteux qui font partie d'une
classe moyenne un peu mieux nantis
joanie et geôles en gagnant semble
actuellement 92 mille dollars par année
lui et militaires et fait l'aller-retour
mirabel montréal chaque jour de semaine
il ya un à le remplir ma voiture pour
une semaine ça nous créé une vraie 45,50
dollars le sait plus trop de 80 pour
réduire nos coûts d'épicerie le plus
possible on va aller vers plus le
cannage ont fait de la conservation va
cuisiner en gros puis malgré ça
joannie est responsable du budget et le
tilt série non dépenses personnelles on
est rendu à 20 $ chaque par semaine ça y
va ils réussissent encore à épargner un
peu mais trois fois moins qu'avant
l'inflation et l'explosion des prix de
l'immobilier sont en train de briser
leur rêve celui de quitter leurs cinq et
demi pour acheter une petite maison dans
les laurentides on peut de moins en
moins se renchérir sur les maisons
faites là on se dit que finalement
peut-être que il leur arrive d'être
propriétaires ont pu apporter les gens
de la classe moyenne qu'à partir du
moment de frapper ta limite d'augmenter
ses revenus qui est à dégraisser son
cochon maximum et qu'elle étudie le gie
plus rien là j'ai pu de l'oise et j'ai
pu départ j'ai pu j'ai pu droit de rêver
mais qu'est ce qu'on fait
dès lors garde au ils ont de grandes
attentes envers le budget du québec
mardi et espère tous des mesures à long
terme plutôt qu'un chèque unique j'ai
suivi les loyers comme ça les
propriétaires vont pouvoir arrêter
d'augmenter sans arrêt offrir les façons
de consommer autrement c'est par exemple
moi je vois dans une maison de la
famille mais je peux avoir des activités
de loisirs c'est gratuit peut-être
d'augmenter le taux de 5 minimum pour
permettre aux gens d'avoir suffisamment
de revenus qu'est ce que vous aimeriez
entendre de ce budget un miracle
un peu d'ironie et surtout l'espoir d'un
répit ici jean-sébastien cloutier
radio-canada mirabel